now this is the first way but there's
another way and it's a bit sneaky now I
want you to think back right when we
were doing areas under curves in the
first distance I mentioned it earlier
maybe some of you didn't catch it the
area under the curve is actually kind of
a it's a shorthand it's not the most
technically accurate way to say what an
integral does the best way to say is
it's an area bounded by an axis that's
okay parent welcome back even integral
gives you an area bounded by an axis
well it kind of implies that you can
choose one axis or another now we've
been doing it to the x-axis this whole
time right well you could do it to the
y-axis if you wanted you just have to
change see how I've got this DX in here
right that tells you which axis you're
going to be integrating with respect to
so if I integrate it with respect to Y
then I would get an area about it to the
y-axis now you can see why that's useful
here if I just get rid of all of my
previous sketching this orange shape
here is between x squared and an axis
it's just the vertical axis not the
horizontal one so what I would need to
do here for method two what I'm going to
do is I'm going to compare this by
integrating with the y axis now this is
a bit sneaky and a bit weird so I'm
going to walk you through it nice and
slowly okay
usually we would say that an area is
equal to something like nought to 4x
squared DX
okay that's the way we normally think
about this and I want you to pay close
attention there so here cuz not actually
the one that we want for starters we say
make a bit bigger number one actually I
take that back it's not for starters
it's the thing on the end but I'm going
to focus on it first DX means we're
looking at the x axis so the area
between your curve which is this guy
over here this curve and the x axis okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
change this DX I'm gonna switch it for a
dy that's the first thing I'm going to
do so in fact I'll write that over here
D Y okay
as me weird integrate with respect to Y
but we can handle this like in the exam
you might remember you had to integrate
something with respect to n so all of
that kind of thing you can integrate
with respect to any variable that you'd
like okay so that's the first thing the
second thing is that's doing a different
color we were integrating a function of
X with respect to X that makes sense
okay but you it's gonna be kind of hard
to integrate a function of X with
respect to Y so I don't want things in
terms of X's I want things in terms of
Y's so let's think about this right what
have I got here well I somehow deleted
that by accident this is y equals x
squared y equals x squared so instead of
saying well this is y in terms of X I
want it to be X in terms of Y hmm let me
say that one more time okay before we
were integrating this x squared thing we
were integrating Y in terms of X but now
I'm doing it all backwards I'm
integrating with respect to Y so I'm
going to change the subject of this
equation okay if I were to take this guy
in here and change the subject to X what
would I do to both sides and I want to
suggest this equation here what can I do
to both sides to make X the subject any
takers okay seeing it or a couple of
different suggestions there all right
right good so yeah I've got a square
here right I want to get rid of a square
so with some caution I'm gonna take the
square root now Ben well done extra gold
star for Ben because I am gonna take the
square root of both sides but I know I'm
integrating right so I'm gonna write
things as I have in the past with a an
index form right rather than using a
square root notation so Y to the power
of 1/2 is equal to X do you see how I've
gotten that by doing X square to the
power of 1/2 and then I get y to the
power of 1/2 okay so this is the thing
I'm integrating now you can see I've
made X the subject I can integrate the
thing in terms of Y so this will be y to
the power of 1/2 dy
now the last thing you can see in this
integral right and we're so used to
looking at it we don't pay attention to
much you've got this four and zero right
the upper and the lower bounds but
there's actually something implied here
that we're just kind of lazy and don't
really right that's what's implied here
is that it's from x equals zero it's an
exponent write to x equals four that's
kind of implied there because you've got
X's everywhere else so this month these
boundaries must be X boundaries as well
but I'm not integrating with respect to
X anymore
I'm well integrating a theme with X's at
all I'm integrating something with Y's
so therefore this integral that I form
I don't want X boundaries I want Y
boundaries so have a look up here where
do I start and where do I end instead of
going from left to right think carefully
now I'm going from bottom to top so
what's the lowest Y value that has that
is connected to my area yeah very good
okay so my lowest one is zero and it
goes all the way up to 16 and this is a
value that we actually saw earlier when
we were working out the rectangle right
so now my Y values or sorry my
boundaries rather are naught to 16 and
what's implied there again we're a bit
lazy because we don't usually write this
but what's implied there is y equals 0
to y equals 16 but the fact that they're
you know you've got all these wires over
here is what implies that the boundaries
are also wires so I'm just going to go
from naught to 16 so before I go any
further we've done a lot of mental work
even though I haven't written very much
okay so I'm gonna write down what were
the three things that we changed number
one you change the variable of
integration
what are you integrating with respect to
okay so it's not of DX anymore
it's a dy then the second thing we
changed was we change the function so
instead of being over here on the right
hand side instead of being Y in terms of
X we said X in terms of Y so we
integrate
the function in terms of Y and then
lastly we did these our boundaries over
here and it was a bit weird that we went
from right to left but this tends to be
the best way it fits in my head anyway
so we changed X boundaries into Y
boundaries and you've got to look
carefully at your sketch to be able to
tell what they are ok so we change them
1 2 3 and now we're ready to go we don't
need to do any stuff with a rectangle
anymore because this integral will
directly give us the area that we're
after let's give it a shot my integral
here I'm going to increase the index so
that gives me Y to the power of 3 on 2
and then I'm going to divide by 3 on 2
then I go from naught to 16 at this
point here I'm going to simplify before
I do my before I do my evaluation of the
upper and lower bounds that divided by 3
over 2 when you divide by a fraction
that's the same as multiplying by the
reciprocal so that's going to be a
multiple of 2/3 out the front and that
leaves me with wide power of 3 on 2 from
naught to 16 ok
well I'm running out of space so I'm
gonna stop there let's see here I got my
2/3 out the front I'm now going to go
this is 16 to the power of 3 on to take
away 0 to the power of 3 onto which is
just 0
I'm gonna sneak up here because I
haven't left enough space for myself
this is 2/3 times ok now 16 to power 3
on 2 I'm going to do the on 2 first so
that's 16th about 1/2 that's 4 and then
I have a 3 on the top so it's 4 cubed so
this is 64 I should have written an
equal sign out the front so this is
equal to 128 over 3 which is exactly
what we got earlier confirming that the
approach we took previously was also
correct
so method 1 we saw that integrating
normally doesn't give us the area that
we want but if you subtract it from a
rectangle then you're good to go you get
the correct area
you just got to identify them carefully
method 2 because we noticed that this
area was bounded to the y-axis it was
going all the way to the left you can
integrate with respect to Y instead of
with respect to X and it works out fine
now for the vast majority of you you're
going to think this second area are the
second method I should say it hurt my
brain like if it's all this new kind of
stuff I have to think about I gotta like
integrate with respect to a weird
variable and then I have to change what
it looks like and then boundaries and it
just is unfamiliar okay why would I do
this now if you were doing this question
honestly I would just as happily in my
own brain if I were doing this question
in an exam I was just as halfway to
method one I don't have to think about
too much complex machinery and I'm much
better integrating with respect to X the
functions get been given to me with
respect to X already somebody's will
just go for it okay but I would say two
things number one this our the method it
sort of gets the heart of well
integration can be with respect to
anything and might be with respect to
time or it might be with respect to the
number of people in a population okay so
the fact that you can integrate with
respect to other things is important and
then secondly depending on the area or
the question you're dealing with
sometimes this is the only way or at
least the only efficient way here's
another example this area is very much
like the area we just dealt with it's
the same function y equals x squared and
it's a very similar part of the graph
but what I'm missing what's different
from the previous question is that I
haven't included this part down here now
if we were to do this using the first
first method using a subtraction of
areas it's going to be a bit more
complicated because the area under a
curve well this area under the curve
here that's kind of not relevant it's
not even touch to the rectangle this
area under the curve is but then you
can't just do one big rectangle you also
have this other second rectangle here it
becomes more complicated very quickly
it's much more succinct to just say oh
this is an area it's bounded to the
y-axis so I'm just going to go from 10
to 16 it's wider power of 1/2 dy off I
go as you might expect the more you do
things like this the more comfortable
you'll get with them but this is the way
that's the most efficient okay so what I
would say Leslie in addition to what
mrs. Lee
which is exactly right is just to be
cautious when you do things like this
right tell us what you're doing like
don't just suddenly start like if for
example I saw this question right in an
exam and in the first line of working
that a student wrote was the integral
from naught to 4 of x squared minus 16
DX with a minus sign at the front okay
this is gonna give you the right answer
I think if I've understood your process
correctly it just kind of it comes out
of nowhere like what do you mean x
squared minus 16 the function I gave you
was not x squared minus 16 you can't
just make it x squared minus 16 because
you want to now it does actually give
you the right answer but you would have
to say something about right okay
you know translating this you know
vertically 16 units in the downward
direction or something like that to
account for the fact that this integral
that you're coming up with is quite
different true the question that you've
you've just given okay so just be
cautious there whenever you want to
change your question now I'm going to
show you an example that in a second um
you can do it to make things simpler for
you just tell us what you're doing
communicate clearly it's not just about
getting a right answer at the end it's
also about showing us why